[Music]
in straight up fronting News why you fry
straight up front submitted by Bart's
Elmo laugh hi hi hi oh yeah he does have
that one what does it sound like like
Elmo rapper bowow is mocked after
posting a photo of a private plane on
Instagram I saw this wait why is it in
quotations you didn't hear about this no
this is the biggest news of 2017 what's
the hashtag bowow challenge # bowow
challenge I've seen the hashtag I don't
know what you got you got to scroll the
Funny Pages okay here's the source
here's the context so on
Insta bow posted this photo and he
captioned it travel day NYC press Run
for the growing up hip hop uh let's go I
promise to bring yall the hottest show
ever May 25th on the WV right okay he
took a photo of this right and so there
was a passenger in the plane with him
that posted at the same same time that
snapped a photo of baow sitting there
and he wrote so this guy little baow was
on my flight to New York but on
Instagram he posted a picture of a
private jet caption traveling to New
York today oh but he was writing coach
shake my head hey but there's a TV in
that coach that's the part I don't get
like he doesn't have to lie cuz he can
afford it m so why why would he lie or
can he afford it yeah he Bow Wow cuz why
is he why is he flying coach I don't
know I don't know why he was flying
coach but the thing is though that this
photo isn't even a photo that he took
himself that's funny goog it apparently
Google
jet so apparently there's this
transportation company that's called Mia
VIP Transportation and so um I couldn't
find the regular photo all I could find
was like the stretched photo version of
it but on this company's website they
have a photo like this oh it's the same
you got the car and you have the other
car here and then you have
the grab this photo oh Bow Wow for what
reason cuz what I don't get about that
is like almost me like going to Whole
Food about to buy some organic broccoli
and then a fan takes a picture of me no
you a [__] you're at Ralphs yeah
but it's cuz like B can't afford this
this is nothing to him I don't know why
he has to lie about something he can
afford maybe he can't afford it yeah
maybe maybe he burned all his money
that's why he's taking coach the Dennis
robman effect yeah
when's that what's the last thing baow
did I don't even think it matters he has
that infinite money does though infinite
yeah does he cuz it makes me wonder like
why is he flying coach not even first
class or economy plus he is also small
so maybe coach is hella huge for him
that's like a [__] Dubai suweet for
his ass he's not little anymore though
so but he's still a small ass dude is he
still small I question everything right
now I don't know I see pictures of him
and he looks small like him and Jermaine
dpri are like the same size so like #t
bow out challenge right now is people uh
putting side by sides or memes together
where it's like pretending to be super
super Chic or Bouie in some way but then
like showing the real truth of it so
this is the first photo and then this is
the second photo so with my man bowow
challenge cover people are [__]
Geniuses it's really funny so then
there's this photo and then this
photo oh oh that's a real
one that's just that one's still pretty
stunning that's not a challenge that's
just Bow Wow you have a good life how
you crop the image is everything yep
that's what social media is though like
we want everyone to see the best parts
of our life this one's super funny and
so it's like you're at a game and you're
just on your phone at the game but then
in reality it's this it's like you
sitting in front of your computer screen
and then there's someone with a lamp and
somebody else with aone to take a pH
it's so much effort that's so genius
that's genius where is that like it's
like in India or something um not too
sure it doesn't look like a Mark I think
the most important thing is that it's in
his living room off a laptop that's a
great photo I need to be creative that
actually should be in the film industry
that was really great lighting I know
that was good you don't even see the
lines on the laptop screen all right
yeah how do you figure that out so the
next one hello bottles for tonight I bet
you they're small I really small that is
tight that's so good perspective is
everything that's so good that is really
good and then this one the car wash one
I seen this and then it's like a tiny
car in the shower
wow I wonder how he feels people are
funny on the internet though the
internet wins all the time all the time
I wonder how bowow feels or is this one
of those like there's no such thing as
bad press I mean but people still got
feelings no you know what I mean like
there's no bad thing but it's like damn
I still feel it in my soul I wish I
could get bow out a [__] Callin
somehow and he could just tell us why he
did that his PR agents just like dude
you got to do this he's just crying
though what's the point I don't get I
don't understand I mean maybe maybe he
is bankrupt or whatever but it's just
hard for me to believe that because of
the amount of projects he's done it's
like that residual income like it's
legendary everyone always talks about
that Hollywood money so I'm just like
how but everyone always talks about that
Hollywood tragedy of spending too damn
much yeah and having to keep up with an
with a certain image that's why I'm a
stay homeless awesome sounds good
what if cuz you said you couldn't find
the original photo right besides a
stretch version so like uh this website
they found a broken URL but then when I
clicked on it like you couldn't even
access anything so yeah I've only saw a
stretched photo of it but it's on this
website because m a VIP Transportation
interesting because his is a full frame
so what if bowow took it when he was
like super hyped and then they took it
stretched it out to make their header
and then he was like old photo yeah bide
is what you're saying yeah yeah maybe he
owns that travel company maybe he does
he owns the travel I think bowow should
be like Keo Reeves and like he should
play The Humble route like look at me I
still take the taxi even though I'm so
rich but that's so anti- hiip hop oh
that's true you got to ball the [__] out
if it's hip-hop though that's true if
it's hip-hop you just got to spend it
all on diamonds yeah like I know I got
rent and I know groceries but I'm just
going to I got this new million dooll
chain who cares that's hip-hop that is
hip-hop damn that's not hip-hop that
sucks when you guys scroll through
Instagram like can you tell if
somebody's faking their life yeah 100%
you can't I'm a social media genius uh
not 100% of the time well I want to hear
I want to hear Joe's first no you don't
I want to hear yours cuz I already know
I'm a genius how do you know it's fake
uh so then you'll see the person right
you'll see like the bags that they're
trying to floss they'll show you like
this my closet so for already from those
things you're just like dude if you're
Lost in You don't like your closet
wouldn't look this sad you know what I
mean or like or even like do you know
what I'm saying like if you're falling
like even just your house like the
mirror that you're taking the picture
from already looks balling like the
attention to detail every single thing
yeah or you look at their signific other
and they're kind of dressed like kind of
average they don't have like a dope
watch or they don't have like dope shoes
they don't necessarily have to be decked
out from head to toe but they doing just
judgeing all day what a judgmental
person how did this turn on me you guys
oh I did this turn this is only 99%
Ballin this belongs to Gio what the [__]
Gio there are thrifty millionaires y hey
I am just very observant I knew a
multi-millionaire that had dirty
cids cord what cids corteroids
corteroids godamn it corduro how do you
spell that corduroy no corduro how do
you spell it so [__]
old it's so old cids that I forgot what
it was
called is it Roy or roids like [__]
hemorrhoids it's not
that don't tell them what it is though
but it's not that all right the world
will never know but anyways this guy was
a multi-millionaire he owner of chains
of restaurants but he always had stains
on his uh polo shirt and it it it was
just horrible he's Chinese yes a th%
Chinese exactly and he would always wear
the same pair of cordoy that would uh
make your statement false cuz every
Chinese billionaire interview I've ever
watched they look like they buy clothes
from the swap me but here's the thing
though he'll have he'll have like a a
name brand belt with a buckle like
that's super loud and that one thing or
he'll have like a [__] watch with
like 30 diamonds and but you're talking
about 100% you're like I didn't say that
that mirror I never said that I never
said that I said the details is what you
can tell and I said they don't have to
be that's the first statement I said
they don't have to be decked out from
head to toe you're talking about some
mirror what you're said the closet no I
was just giving you a that bag why you
got that LV bag but then your closet
looks like this that's what you're were
saying I could tell in a heartbeat
sometimes you see like a homeless white
guy in dreadlocks and he's in the jungle
and then you're like oh he's so poor but
people don't know that he actually owns
that 3 acres of land and he's doing some
type of farming how can you tell what
what are the they'll probably say I own
this land and I have a you a genius in
the caption he actually is the caption
is there a big difference between like
faking it to make it like that versus
even like I don't know people on IG that
take selfies and like butter themselves
up or use filters I think it's the same
thing I think it's the same thing
everybody should just # bowow Challenge
on their selfies now that challenge yeah
and then the real photo yeah they come
out [__] up I can tell it's like if
you have the lowest level of a luxury
car and all your luxury items is very
the the bare minimum level that entry
level of luxury like so for example like
what is the entry level Mercedes now is
it cclass now how many BMWs are there
I'm not even into it so I don't know I
know it was like the one series or some
[__] or it was like a small or two it's
basically the same price of a Corolla or
Camry oh what I I'm exaggerating but
it's it's basically equivalent to like
buying a Japanese car yeah you're the
idea of buying the name right or buying
the status yeah or like it's like
getting a GU it's like Gucci like
t-shirt
but nothing else is Gucci you're not
even getting the top level one I guess
moral the story is just don't fake it
why the quickest way to become poor is
try to prove that you're rich yep bam
philosophies hey guys hope you enjoyed
that episode please don't miss a beat
And subscribe cuz if you don't subscribe
you don't know when a new video is
uploaded but for more videos click up
[Music]
here
n